[Music]  she threw it back like she lived with  her granny  all cheeks that little day granted he's  sneaking out the house man they freaky  oh is it like because they want to get  out of the house  like i don't know it's just like they'd  be the most rebellious yeah just think  of everybody who live with their  grandparents and not their fans  i don't know anyone you never grew at  school and somebody say  they live big room  [Music]  that's why you can't open up your third  eye to the booth  so  okay i get it so the freaky girls are  the ones that live with their  grandparents that's what that lyric  means  okay  that's kind of cool sad  [Music]  didn't make it better  you